hey everybody it's Monday yep and it's
movie time yeah just like we do yep hope
you guys had a good weekend mine was
pretty good but you know had that
funeral to go to I had a good day
today yeah you did yeah
I ain't saying
nothing you're not saying nothing yeah
why'd you even bring it up then I
know they sold my dad's truck I got
three grand for that and then they sent
me what was in his bank account and it
was much more than I thought it was
going to
be yeah so you know solved all my
problems it did yeah so yeah it was good
going to be able to get I couldn't solve
all the Jen's problems with it though
well couldn't pay my problems are too
big for anyone to solve
right it's okay I'm used to it
yeah I'm used to being brok credit cards
are [__] it's been like that my whole
life yeah so I'm just I'm just kind of
like yep yeah I'm screwed what else is
new um we'll we'll get it paid off I
know eventually eventually it's not that
bad I mean you know no it's humanly
possible like a lot of people have way
way way more credit card Deb than I have
that would take several years five it
probably would yeah yeah five years
probably it probably would yeah we just
got to chip away at it yeah that's all
you got to do if not it just [__]
kill us Z said congrats Tom you didn't
tell me you became a millionaire
today I feel like a [__]
millionaire I feel like a millionaire
[__] shopping on Teemu with that
[__] [__] I won't have a problem
buying a car we put it that way which is
good because we've been needing one yeah
so and um I could buy a car car and a
motorcycle with this but I think I'm
going to buy a car and pay up my credit
cards yeah that would probably be the
best thing that would be the most
sensible thing to do cuz we really do
need another car cuz we share a car cuz
you have motorcycles and we don't
commute anywhere so we don't drive a lot
but my car is it's still runs it's very
reliable but it's 20 years old I could
buy a used car a decent used car and a
decent used Harley or yeah or a decent
used definely definitely a decent used
Indian
I can afford an Indian Scout for easy
you can buy whatever you want yeah just
pay it all out right you wouldn't have
to find it yeah so so that was some good
news we had today yeah um yeah so thank
you very much to zanada for sending us
this movie also sent us the Departed
which we will be talking about next
Monday uh Mrs peacock says I hate this
movie just my
opinion some people do but it really
does seem like the
overarching uh you know opinion about
this movie is that it's a masterpiece
and I would tend to agree I did see this
movie did I see it in the theater I kind
of feel like I did Maybe not maybe I saw
it like maybe I rented it when it came
out so this was actually my second
viewing but you had never seen it before
no if you like The Batman
series and and James Bond like7 and the
matrix it's all kind of combined in the
same I actually like this better than
the Matrix yeah well it's a little more
up to date than the matrix it's got some
better effects it's kind of a it's kind
of a more plausible story I don't know
both those stories are kind of equally
plausible or implausible depending on
how you want to look at it um it's a
good movie though it's got [__]
killer cast Allstar the acting is really
good the special effects are really good
it's a very complicated movie though you
you really got to pay attention yeah
it's long
there's enough for what are you doing
Pope she's tearing up my bookshelf
there's enough for two movies here
easily um it's uh it's complicated it it
would take I'd have to see this several
times to actually I think pick up on
everything I think because I was missing
a lot of stuff I was like wait a minut
hold on what's what's happening now I
had to kind of and I will tell you that
there is a [__] ton of like Easter egg
type stuff going on like in the
background with like the numbers and the
music and it's like there's all kind of
[__] going on in this that you don't
really pick up unless you see it a bunch
of times visually it's
great oh the acting is really good
DiCaprio [__] knocks it out of the
park everybody's Michael Kane's in it he
[__] he's great yeah he's not in it
much but yeah he's in it he uh all kinds
of just any everybody that's in this
movie is great I really love the
Ensemble I think like everybody works
really well Tom Hardy's in it he's
[__] great in it uh it's basically
all the cast of Batman's in it well yeah
like I said Heath Ledger isn't but well
but you know he it's got everybody else
in
it that's good flick yeah Danny rling
said dark city is the first Matrix style
film and the best you know what I don't
think we've ever reviewed dark city
[__] love dark city you would
probably really dig it SE yeah I've only
seen that's another movie I feel like
you need to see I've only seen scenes
from it it looked really good oh it's
awesome it's awesome yeah um and I feel
like a lot of people like a lot of
people like you know slobber on the knob
of the Matrix and stuff and I'm I like
the Matrix I'm not saying that but I
think it's in my opinion The Matrix is
slightly overrated I think um but it a
movie of his time Dark City kind of got
there first I want to say because I
think dark city came out a year before
the Matrix did it not I thought it came
out in '98 and I thought the Matrix came
out of '99 this movie is about basically
corporate spies and their job is is to
invade people's dreams they have the
technology to do it and to get
information from them
by way of their dreams like from their
subconscious from their subconscious
they're called extractors yeah and a lot
of the stuff that's happening is in this
movie is happening inside these dream
worlds so it's kind of like the
Matrix um they end up taking this
Mission not to take ideas out of a guy's
head or information out of a head but to
implant an idea into somebody's head
Inception and then yeah to get this guy
to sell off his father's Empire that's
what is he had all these monopolies and
[__] and that that's what the mission is
and uh they weren't sure if it was
possible but the guy the main character
played by Leonardo DiCaprio he thought
it could be possible because it turns
out he tried it on his wife well he
didn't try he did it on he did it but it
wasn't totally successful in the way it
it worked but it it killed her but it
went bad in in the worst way imaginable
right so a bunch of [__] happens about
it yeah well I really do like cuz Okay
so Christopher Nolan obviously wrote and
directed this movie and he started
working on this idea way back in 2002
like right after he made insomnia which
is also a good movie and it took him a
really long time I think he came up with
this concept he liked the idea of like
dream Steelers as he called it so he
wrote this kind of treatment and then he
was like you know I feel like I need
more experience do like big budget kind
of movies like epic kind of movies
because this needs that because it's
about dreams and you can go crazy with
it so he actually kind of put it on the
back shelf until he made Batman Begins
which I think was 2005 uh then he made
the prestige which is also [__] great
I love the prestige I think we might
have did we did we review The Prestige
please tell me we did cuz I love that
the book is great too if you I don't
remember which one that was about that
was about the two rival uh magicians
remember David Bo was in it as
Tesla I never got to see it oh so maybe
we didn't review it no we didn't review
it oh it's awesome I love the prestige I
also wanted to see the one about the guy
he was playing Tesla who was making
copies of himself and killing himself
yeah that's what this is the same one
yeah that's the prestige okay yeah
spoiler alert
yeah but yeah so um you that Tesla
technology yeah the book is great too
it's by uh Christopher priest I think WR
the book but yeah I have it in here
somewhere um I think my brother gave it
to me actually now I'm thinking about it
and then he also made The Dark Knight
before he made this one so he wanted to
kind of like build up to doing this one
because he wanted it to be like really
big and epic it turned out this movie
cost a lot to make I think it was 160
million however it made all it made over
800 million like on and was one of the
highest grossing movies that year and it
got nominated for a bunch of awards and
[__] like that and I think that a lot of
people cuz 2010 I was kind of watching
some other reviews and like looking at
some other movies that came out in 2010
a lot of people that are real into
Cinema was like 2010 was kind of a [__]
year like it you know a lot of really
good movies didn't come out I mean Black
Swan and stuff like that came out but um
so there weren't like a lot of really
good ones so everybody was like just you
know just really amazed that this movie
came out in the summer and it's kind of
like a big epic Blockbuster type of
movie but it's also like really
intelligent and like really intricate
and a lot of critics were like really
jazz about that cuz I said that just
goes to show that you can make an
intelligent movie that doesn't hold the
audience's hand but still make it like
this big epic summer blockbuster that's
really successful yeah and we got sent
this Movie Blu-Ray from zanada who's in
the uh comment section right now so I
want to give him a shout out and thanks
for sending us this movie if you send us
a movie we review it as soon as possible
I mean go to the front of the line yeah
when we get to it and uh but no I I
agree he was Zan sent me two movies The
other one was uh another Leonardo Deca
The Departed the Departed which is which
is Martin scors we're going to see that
one next that's I know that's going to
be good because of Martin scors that one
is good it is good but what me me and
zanada had a couple of other DiCaprio
flicks in common like we both like Romeo
and Juliet which I think is a
masterpiece a great flick if you haven't
seen it see it it's baz lurman and I
really like baz lurman a lot some people
don't he's very fizzy and over the top I
get that but fun movie yeah I like great
soundtrack uh accurate to the to to The
Source material um just just a good
flick so but the thing is is that I had
only
seen that
movie The Aviator which didn't make a
huge impression on me really yeah it was
all right it was okay but it didn't make
a big and then I saw uh Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood and that movie blew me away
and I was like man I didn't know that
deao was a good actor yeah because I
only knew him really from like child
roles right or not I don't call child
rolles I think that was young guy yeah
that was kind of a [__] DiCaprio is
good man he's good he's a good actor I I
gained a lot of respect from him
watching these movies I want to see
blood diamond too which some people say
it's a great movie other people say well
it's just I really liked it yeah I want
to see that one too I only saw it once
but I really liked it yeah I was
watching um Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood I I was impressed with
DiCaprio I thought I was seeing an
unusual performance by him like wow he
he did something good no all of his
movies are good he he can act I just
wasn't aware of it you know I wasn't a
fan yeah I mean we now we kind of got
off on the Leonardo decaprio thing
because of shudder Island which we
reviewed last week Shuter Island's a
[__] Masterpiece which was great yeah
yeah it's one of that's like one of the
top movies I've seen that's a great M
it's up there with [__] d uh Dam na
what's it called uh uh nightmare alley
nightmare alley almost said Dam Nation
alley that's another movie that's a
different movie yeah yeah nightmare
alley is a [__] great flick he's not
in it but those two movies see are real
similar to me see nightmare alley if you
like like uh a [__] um what was the
name was
it I've been drinking not that much
nightmare alley was G Del and it's and
it's a remake from mie I think from the
night it was from a novel too Zach says
I just remember this movie Inception is
where all the Han Zimmer memes came from
yeah because this movie when it came out
in 2010 as far as I'm aware the trailer
for the movie was the first one or at
least the first one in release to use
that now
ubiquitous noise so um so it kind of
became like a joke because everybody
else started they like hey that's pretty
cool we're going to use that now because
that does turn up a lot and it's Han
Zimmer I mean he's done a bajillion like
really great movie scores but he did do
that in this so um so yeah it that kind
of became a thing afterwards so I can
see if you're seeing it now and didn't
realize that this was kind of the first
one to do that you're just like oh God
here we go again with all the big like
I'm kind of noises but um but yeah this
was kind of the first one this movie
cemented DiCaprio as a top actor like
okay yeah yeah okay and well the thing
about it like he worked the thing okay I
got he's telling me I Gotta See Jango on
chain he say he's awesome in that too
okay all
right and also Zach says Gangs of New
York is great too I really I saw that in
the theater DiCaprio's in
that was he I don't think he is in that
I can't remember it's been a while like
I said I saw it in the it was a good
movie I haven't seen it in a long time
yeah I I remember basically true a lot
of the stuff you saw yeah it was based
on kind of a true story but yeah so the
thing about so Christopher Nolan um the
cool thing about him is that he seems
like a filmmakers filmmaker in the sense
that he's really really into Cinema as
an art form and so he'll really use
stuff that like homages his favorite
movies like for example in Inception um
you know which most people know but if
you haven't seen it it kind of operates
on it's kind of complicated to get into
but it but it sort of operates on three
distinct dream levels each one of those
levels he based on a different movie
that he was into the top dream level
which was in like downtown LA or
whatever with the train coming through
like on the road and everything he based
that on heat the Michael Man movie which
we just reviewed not too long ago uh the
second one down which was like in the
weird Hotel he kind of based on The
Shining and then the third one down he
based on uh the James Bond movie on his
on uh Her Majesty's Secret
Service so I was right about this Bond
yeah yeah yeah well and you're not the
only person cuz I watched um uh a very
old like Chris Duckman review of this
and he said yeah this is basically like
the Matrix meets James Bond so it's kind
of like so it's like an action movie he
I think he wrote it initially like as a
horror film but then he decided to go
Heist movie this is a essentially a
heist movie yeah but set but more like
sci-fi with some kind of horror elements
I feel okay like a mission impossible
flick yeah yeah it's a team of spies
they're going to try to pull this
Mission off all acting together which
you know I love Mission Impossible
especially the newer Mission Impossibles
you know Tom Cruz he he he Nails it he
could he can compete with 007 franchise
Within mission impossible it it reminds
me of Mission Impossible more than James
Bond more more like that yeah I get you
because they're a team right James Bond
James working on his own yeah that's
true you know I mean you do get like I
know Leonardo DiCaprio is obviously like
the star of the show like he's the main
guy he's the bond but yeah but there is
like an ensemble thing where everybody
has their own role to play and but in in
the sense that I mean particularly the
the more recent Bond movies with Daniel
Craig where he's more of like a wounded
uh kind of character you know what I
mean where they go like more into his
psychology I guess well they're grinding
him down man right so I feel like in
that sense because the whole thing about
Leonardo DiCaprio's character in this
whose name is Cobb by the way um is that
I mean he's [__] up right he can't
really build dream worlds anymore like
he used to because he can't get over the
death of his wife of guilt over having
caused it essentially indirectly and you
know and the fact that his conception of
her in his subconscious keeps like
bleeding into his missions and like
[__] them up yeah you know what I
mean and it seems like it's kind of like
getting worse and worse yeah and you
know he can't really let go of her yeah
I see the bond parallel that you're
talking yeah now for some people there
are some people out there maybe
listening that didn't like the Daniel
Craig James Bond they were too dark and
that hey it was too negative that's
actually closer to the damn Source
material Bond was not a [__] a Happ
happy dude you know they had to pull him
out of the gutter at the beginning of
most of the books to clean him back up
and get him back on his mission you know
um but I I I was I'm a huge fan of B of
the [__] of many of the bond serieses
you know because they're not all the
same but I love the Daniel Craig
ones I got all I got them all on Blu-Ray
so um but yeah I see what you're talking
about that there are some Bond parallels
but the tone reminds more of Mission
Impossible yeah yeah which yeah I see
Mission Impossibles yeah but it's great
though you know it's great yeah that's I
mean the thing about it like I said and
I think that it's kind of more I think
the initial thing was that Christopher
Nolan he even said like in interviews
that he wanted to do this more like a
heist movie but then he's like you know
they're they're usually heist movies are
kind of more action oriented and you
don't really have like a big like
emotional core or anything like that so
as it turned out I think that him and
Leonardo DiCaprio worked together on
that character to add more emotional
resonance to like to make it I don't
want to say like a love story at the
middle of it kind of is but the whole
one of the themes of the movie is Cobb
you know the character of Cobb trying to
learn
to let go of his dead wife and live in
reality now we do want to discuss this
and this is kind of spoilery and stuff
like that but honestly I don't think can
you even spoil this movie is it possible
to spoil this movie because if you talk
about things that happened in the movie
and you haven't seen the movie then they
won't have any context for you so it
doesn't really spoil it you know what
I'm saying cuz like I said it's
complicated it's taking place the main
bulk of the action is taking place
simultaneously on three subconscious
dream levels you know what I mean so
there's different [__] going on at each
and then there's like another level up
here that's you presume is reality and
then you find out that there's another
level under that which is kind of like a
limbo type of thing so you essentially
have like a five layer cake going on and
you have to keep track and like I said
this is where it gets confusing the
movie doesn't really it doesn't Pander
like it doesn't really like it going to
slow down and tell you what's happen it
explains how [__] works it explains what
the rules are and it generally does to
those rules but it trusts you to keep up
right you got to keep up so you really
do have to like pay attention what's
going on so like I said it would I think
it would be who most people to like see
it a couple of times just so you catch
everything and the Matrix would pattern
to you the matx see that's why I didn't
like it the Matrix would explain to you
exactly what was going on you know what
I mean and they they were very slow with
you which I think that made it a
successful movie because come on let's
let's be honest the average person in a
theater 100 IQ half of dumber than that
they need to have their hands held to
walk through it they'll [__] really
they'll really enjoy it especially if
they're young Y young guys really like
the Matrix because it was like a New
Concept yeah that's another thing about
this movie had I seen this as a teenager
I probably would have liked it even
more you know what I mean was all the
weird [__] that was happening I mean
it's a concept I'm seeing it as a jaded
54 year old and I'm going yeah that's a
that's a cool idea but I was recognizing
a lot of the
the tricks that it was doing you know I
was like I know where I know where they
got this well yeah yeah you're right he
is a James Bond type character like like
Daniel Greg but he's within a team kind
of like uh kind of like uh Mission
Impossible they're kind of doing the
Matrix and it's also kind of like a a
heist flick but the mission impossible
flicks are kind of like Heist flicks and
honestly there's nothing new Under the
Sun really I mean you can't do anything
new really you can just take tropes and
things like that remix them into a way
that's original which this absolutely
does okay Nolan man he did a great job
in Batman there's not really going to be
anything new in
Batman he did kind of freshen it up and
give you a different version of it I
thought it was really good but the
Batman concept's not very original this
is as original as you're gonna get for
Nolan this is Nolan's [__] taale he's
talented we still need to do momento by
the way I haven't seen that one which
came out yeah years before this one okay
well I told yeah I told Tom I was like
okay well it's about um a guy who can't
form new memories like yeah short memory
last I said so the whole entire movie is
filmed in backwards order the scenes are
all in backwards order and he was just
kind of like um no I don't think I'm
ready for that so I'm like it's really
good though I didn't have a hard time
following it but this one I can see I
did not have a hard time following it
but I can see how people would because
like I said it doesn't you really really
really have to like pay pay attention to
everything that people say and like
what's going on because it goes back and
forth like all the time so basically
like I said the plot of it is is you
have Leonardo de caprio's character is
Cobb who is an extractor his whole job
which it's implied is not entirely legal
I mean it's corporate Espionage right so
it's not entirely on the up and up so
his whole job is to go they've developed
they don't go too much into this it's
not too like hard sci-fi or anything but
they just kind of offhandedly mention
that this kind of shared dream
technology which is engendered somehow
through like some chemistry type thing
which like I said it's not important um
you know they they don't bog the movie
down with explaining the wise and
wherefores of how the [__] Works they're
just like we can do it okay just move on
so they have like a shared dream space
and if you can go into somebody else's
dream and take information from them and
then you can give it to others so he
gets paid like big money for like by
these big corporations to go into other
people's dreams and extract useful
information that the other companies can
use to [__] them over you know what I
mean so that's what he's doing at the
beginning like him and a couple of his
other team members so that's what he's
doing at the beginning um but he doesn't
succeed however it turns out that the
guy who was his Mark the guy who was
whose dreams he was going into um Saito
who's this big like wealthy business
owner he's like I'll tell you what um
you know he pretty much has all the
money in the world and he's like if you
do this job for me I will make it so
that you can um go back home and see
your family which he's not been able to
do because of like a murder charge he
can't go back to the United States and
blah blah so he's like I can fix all
that for you because he has all the
money in the world like I said he's like
but what I want you to do is go into the
mind of the son of this big huge like
company owner that was like a rival
company to cidos and he's like I want
you to go in there and plant an idea in
his head that that he can break his
dad's company up like after his dad
croaks right and he's like and then I
can kind of take over and blahy blah so
that's what he wants him to do so
they're talking about inception which is
imp planning an idea in someone's head
now it sounds like an easy thing to do
but apparently not so they do kind of
explain that to do this you have to put
the idea in the person's head so that
they think it's their own idea so all of
this because there's a whole thing
that's like I said that's kind of
explained as they go that if you are in
somebody else's head and that person's
subconscious recognizes that you are
essentially an alien invader then the
subconscious will like come after you so
like in that sense the way that comes
across on the screen as people like
looking at you and then like they start
getting increasingly hostile as they
recognize you are not supposed to be
there you know what I mean so that's
kind of how they how they kind of show
it in the movie and also there's a thing
where if like some people know that this
exists that people can like creep around
in your dreams and like steal your
information and stuff so some of the
higher Mucky mucks like rich people and
stuff have hired other companies to like
give them like mental things they can do
to like fob that off you know what I
mean and again that manifests is like
essentially like a security detail so if
you go inside their dreams then all like
all these like army dudes with guns come
out and start shooting at you and blah
blah now if you die in the dream it
doesn't kill you in real life it just
wakes you up however this one mission
that they're going on where they're
supposed to incept or put this idea in
this dude's head and make him think it's
his own idea to do this they have to go
super super deep like I said they build
this three level subconscious thing that
they're going to you know bring this
dude into essentially and like make him
think that it's
reality so they're going to do that but
they get this they get the um Services
of this chemist who has come up with
this really good [__] that has like this
super cative in it you can go like super
way deep like way deeper than normal
only problem is that if you die when
you're way down deep on one of these
dream levels um you don't wake back up
your subconscious essentially goes gets
kicked out into this limbo type place
and you don't really come back from it
and you find out later that Leonardo
DiCaprio's character him and his wife
had gotten lost in this dream limbo for
what to them seemed like 50 years even
though it was only one night because
that's another thing like the the deeper
down you go like the T there's time
dilation so that's another thing that
you have to kind of keep track of and
like I said the best [__] part of
this where they're doing the whole big
heist where they're trying to you know
essentially implant this idea in Killian
Murphy's mind is they have the three
layers going on at once because they
have different members of the team like
on the different layers because they
have to like wake the people up at a
particular time and all this other kind
of stuff so on the top layer to do what
they call a kick like to wake people up
he basically like backs the van like
over this [__] overpass so it takes
like even though in real life it would
just take what like less than a minute
like to fall into the water you know
they're three levels down and so to them
it takes like an hour so so you see this
van just slowly slowly like while
they're like trying to do [__] like down
cuz they have longer time but you know
what I mean so that's so you really have
to kind of keep track of all and the
crazy thing about this there's there's
massive numbers of videos on YouTube
explaining all of the little Easter eggs
and weird little details and [__] like
that they said one of the coolest things
is that the song they use uh that Edith
P Off song that they use to um signal to
everybody like when a kick is coming so
they're like hey wrap your [__] up we're
going to wake y'all up now um that song
is 2 minutes and 28 minutes 2 minutes
and 28 seconds long and the movie is 2
hours and 28 minutes long and he
probably did that on purpose but like
everything about like all the numbers on
the [__] like the number on the train uh
is the same as like the hotel room
number but like reversed it's just like
all of this crazy [__] and he did it all
on purpose um all of their names like
the first names of all their names
together spell like dreams pay or
something like that there's all kind of
crazy little details in there about the
[__] so here's the thing that a lot of
people people why people still talk
about this [__] movie is the
ending yeah
now and Christopher Nolan himself has
said this is the one question that
people more than any movie that I've
ever made he's like people ask me this
question all the [__] time and he's
like and they ask me it almost as if
like I'm going to answer it which I mean
he kind of has though but there's still
like a lot of theories about this
basically if youve seen the movie you
know the end of it has has Leonard
DiCaprio supposedly getting back home
and seeing his children which is all he
wanted right and this is supposedly the
real world now he has this spinning top
that um that he's been using and they've
established that that's how he uh knows
if he's still in a dream or not because
he's kind of losing track sometimes um
if it just keeps spinning instead of
falling
over so at the very end of the movie
when he comes back to his house and like
sees his kids out in the yard
he does the top on the table and then he
goes out to see his kids and the top
still spinning and then we Fade to Black
we cut to Black and the credits roll so
a lot of people are like ah what the
[__] like what does that mean like is he
really is this the real world is it
going to fall over is he really or you
know what I mean now what Christopher
Nolan has said at least what I
interpreted and other people have said
this too is that he's like the point of
that wasn't whether the top fell over or
not the point of it was that he didn't
care if it fell over or not because he
just spun it and he left it there
because they said several points during
the movie he would obsessively like spin
it to make sure like it felt it's like
oh my God am I in the real world or is
this a dream or whatever because in a
dream it would just keep spinning so
he's like the whole point of that last
scene was that it didn't matter he
didn't look at it he was just like oh
there are my kids I'm going to go so if
this is a dream it didn't matter to him
that's kind of that his children were
more important important and he just
chose to accept this reality now there
are theories floating around out there
that um I mean I think I don't know I
think that he did actually get back to
reality although I know that there are
arguments against that as well which are
perfectly valid some people have argued
that Ari
Adney uh Ellen Elliot Page's character
that she came up with cuz she seemed
very concerned about she was the one
that constructed all the
uh mazes like all the subconscious
worlds right the dream worlds and she
seemed very concerned about his
inability to keep his wife from like
[__] up their mission because you
know it wasn't his wife it was his
conception of her like his guilt about
her death and she kept popping up and
[__] up their [__] and she was
concerned about that rightly so because
she was on this job too so some people
have said that AR Adney made um a Dream
World for him
without telling him and had put him in
it had incepted it you know into him
without him being the wiser which I
suppose I don't really see that there's
anything in the movie that would negate
that I mean that could be the case but
like I said I think the point of the
last scene is that it didn't matter to
him anymore you know what I mean like
even if they're not real cuz that was
kind of the whole thing was that and I
like like that he kind of left it like
that because now you're sitting there
thinking well wait what well is anything
real anymore like there's was this whole
movie not real you know reality is a
point of view yeah and I kind of think
that's the point he was making yeah was
that he said he was in Dreamland with
his wife for 50 [__] years yeah and
then they did all this [__] they weren't
though they were just asleep and they
were just asleep for like one night for
one night but to them it seemed like 50
years for them it was 50 years they
bought into it I've ever had a dream
like that yeah I have too yeah yeah I've
never had a dream like that where was
like 50 years but I've had dreams where
it was like a seemed like it was where
it was like a long time couple days
yeah but it's it's very
jumpy yeah but they said they got good
at it kind of like uh it was like lucid
dreaming lucid dreaming yeah they built
like a whole world down there
yeah theoretically you might be able to
do it kind of but I don't think you can
do it well like I said it's a
fascinating concept it's a good concept
yeah because you know even if it doesn't
cuz the thing about you could go really
wild with this but the thing about it
cuz Tom like cuz at one point he said
well man you'd think they'd be coming up
with all kind of like crazy weapons and
all this kind of [__] I said yeah but
the whole point of their job is to
either ex that was the cats
runat I just hear him running around
chasing each other in the hallway um the
whole point of their job was to either
extract or implant information and to do
that you kind of want the [__] to be
sort of realistic because I'm thinking
if it's like too
Fantastical then the people will be like
wait what the [__] is going like they'll
they'll be aware that they're dreaming
you know what I mean but there is crazy
[__] that happens in this and like the
visual effects in this are amazing and
when I cuz we're I'm sitting there
thinking I remember when I first saw
this and that great [__] fight scene
with um Joseph Gordon levit and like
fighting the people in the the spinning
hallway like because in the one dream
layer up their van is falling off the
overpass or the bridge or whatever and
so they're kind of flying through space
so one dream level down cuz he's
sleeping in the van so he's like flying
around all over like this hotel room for
but he's like used to it because he does
this all the
time and I'm watching that and I didn't
look it up at the time cuz I was like
man that looks so good it does not look
like CGI you know why cuz it's not that
is not CGI they built a hotel room
hallway SP yeah in a hamster wheel
essentially yeah and then just had them
kind of like yeah so it do what they
were doing really good yeah High Desert
said that um he he thought that cell
with Jennifer Lopez was a a great movie
I love that movie that movie we should
probably review that one that movie
starred Jennifer Lopez and her booty and
it was a [__] great movie two
separate yeah yeah of course that's kind
yeah of course man she brought the booty
along with it but um yeah I brought my
booty today usually I would leave it at
home but today I brought with but
any but anyway uh she did I did that
[__] on purpose people but uh that was a
good movie uh she was penetrating the
dream world of a serial killer trying to
find yeah where uh where he had stashed
some uh female victim that he had in a
Cell where he was going to drowned her
that was a cool flick I haven't seen it
in a long time yeah I remember the
visuals being really really crazy now he
said it was a better
movie one of the things that made a
different movie it's different what made
that movie really good is that it was it
was relatively simple and accessible uh
this movie is not simple it's it's it's
a lot more
complicated it's just a different kind
of movie uh but the cell was good cell
was easy to follow though it was yeah it
was well and like I said I you said
about the Matrix I mean that seemed like
a pretty simple concept this is not a
super complex comp you know concept but
the way that it's executed they're
telling three stories at once towards
the end or four stories yeah so you
really have to keep track of where
everybody is like who's who's on this
level what's going on in the real level
you know where's the real world and then
there's all that other stuff like the
subplot about him and his the
relationship between him and his wife
and it's just kind of like you know is
this the real world when he comes out of
it at the end because cuz it's kind of
seems like maybe not and it's just you
know cuz some people have said oh when
he sees his kids at the end they're in
the exact same position and like wearing
the same clothes that they were like
every time he sees them in his memories
but I don't know most impressive thing
about the cell is that JLo can actually
act she's actually good well yeah she I
didn't I didn't expect it when I was
watching it I was like yeah she's GNA
this is going to be stupid no she she I
bought it she was like yeah she can act
she hasn't been in very many movies
though has she no she's been a [__] ton
of movies what are you talking about
yeah guess I yeah she's been a [__] so
that's well it's good because she can
act yeah I think yeah I think people are
always skeptical like when somebody
who's mainly known for one thing like
singers and stuff and it's like oh they
want to be in a movie now [__] off
Vanilla Ice trying to be in a movie yeah
well and I can see why people are
skeptical because most of the 99% of the
time that [__] does not work out just
you know stay in your lane but there are
always those people that are
multi-talented you know so you never
know just give everybody a chance you
know what I mean Danny ring said this
sort of sounds sounds like that Dennis
Quaid dream film oh Dreamscape from 1984
it's um not really I well I think the
just the general concept of you know a
shared dream world is similar but I love
Dreamscape but you know it was the 80s
um it was like I said it was a lot more
straightforward concept this one is a
lot
more complex you know and like I said
there's a lot more it's like it's
basically like a heist film but taking
place like in a dream world but um but
like I said they they do a lot of cool
[__] with all the special effects and
everything and I was actually quite
surprised to learn that most of the
special effects in this are practical
other than the stuff which obviously
they couldn't do uh practically because
there is um a scene where uh when Cobb
first takes Ari Adney into a dream world
to kind kind of explain to her you know
the job they want her to do like and
everything so that she's kind of like
the audience insert in that way because
that's kind of how they explain the
rules of like how to do this and
everything like that because she's kind
of new coming out of the team she's like
a college student and stuff and she's
going to be the person that's going to
construct all these dream worlds for the
guy that they're going to implant the
idea into so he takes her into a dream
world in Paris even she doesn't know
it's a dream and she immediately like
takes right to it and starts doing all
kind of crazy [__] you know what I mean
like she makes the whole city like fold
back on itself and [__] like that which
looks really really good but I like that
they didn't go too over the top with it
you know but there's like all these kind
of little details in there that are like
that you don't really notice the first
time you watch it but then like later on
you watch it like one of the things that
I didn't actually realize until I was
like reading another review of it is the
reason that when they go down to the
first layer of the dream world which is
like the dream La the reason that it's
pouring down rain which it doesn't
usually do in LA by the way is because
Yousef the chemist had to pee really bad
cuz they were on the plane like you know
they were on the plane the whole time he
had a pee really bad so he dreamed that
it was raining really hard but it's just
like and I was just like oh my god I
didn't even realize that but there's
like all kind of like little details
like that that you don't really notice
unless you see but yeah so oh and even
the the shot of all of them in the van
going over the bridge like when they're
underwater like in they did that for
real that's not CGI or anything like
that and they were like yeah when we
were passing the the scuba gear back and
forth yeah that we were really doing
that so we had to be under there for
like several minutes at a time and like
they're trying to do is they're trying
to make sure that those effects would
hold up and they do because Matrix
effects didn't really hold up you know
some of the [__] that they were doing
dodging bullets it looked cool at the
time but you look at those scenes now
and you you see what they did yeah know
just yeah well that's why I'm always a
big advocate of whenever possible please
do the effects practically um you know
it just it will never date you know what
I mean yeah really uh not the same way
that CGI will I mean look at [__] that
was made in the 90s with C other than
Jurassic Park which still looks pretty
[__] great good yeah but you see
other movies made in the 90s and 2000s
with CGI and a lot of it looks like [__]
yeah especially if they didn't spend
like you know millions and millions of
dollars on it you know it just looks
cheesy they didn't really get it right
until recently and even recent films
with CGI don't look it still looks a
little uncanny valley to me like you can
still tell that it's CGI that's CGI is
like what they did on Fury Road where it
was all real but they used CG to uh get
rid of the damn tire tracks yeah like
minimal yeah and safety harnesses were
taken
out but everything else was [__] real
and that seems to be what they tried to
do with this one I mean Christopher
Nolan basically said he's like I want to
do as much practically in camera as
possible like I said the City of Paris
folding over on itself obviously you
have to do that with CGI but they did a
really good job of making that look
realistic you know what I mean it still
doesn't look super now in Fury Road some
people thought that the fire coming out
of the guitar was CG it's not it's
practical and then that and that that
truck that had the stage on it when it's
wreck they thought that was CG it's not
no they wrecked the real truck they
wrecked that truck the way all that [__]
went flying off and everything it was
all it was practical now the steering
wheel that came and swallowed up the
camera that was CG but but that truck
crashing was real just that the way it
was shot the frame rate made it look
kind of weird yeah but yeah most of the
um you know yeah Zan said will the
visuals in this movie hold up 20 years
from now or will it look like bad CGI it
hold up yeah this movie in particular
cuz like I said I saw that this came out
in 2010 and I saw it probably in 2011
2012 something like that and I remember
it looking like really really good and
then I didn't know that most of the um
effects have been done practically so
when we saw it again and particularly
that fight scene in the hallway I was
like holy [__] that looks [__] great
I was like that looks real like that
does not look like 2010 CGI at all and
then I found out later it's like it's
cuz it's not it's because it's not they
did it for real like they had an actual
rotating hallway and uh he basically had
I think he had a safety harness
obviously but um you know he just had to
kind of
maneuver around and like not get hit by
the lights and all that other kind of
[__] they had to like rehearse it and
all and everything and like I said they
you know all the underwater shots and
stuff like that they really did all of
that for real and you can tell um it
looks really really good still which a
lot of movies from 2010 um do not but um
but yeah so I don't know so what I don't
know what everybody's theories about
this movie are whether you actually
think that the whole thing was Leonardo
DiCaprio's dream and like he wasn't even
uh in reality at the end or I don't know
I kind of think he was but some people
are like like I said about the oh the
kids didn't look any older and they had
the same clothes on and why was Michael
Kane there because I thought he lived in
Paris and what is he doing in you know
in the US like wherever they landed and
all this other kind of stuff and nobody
talked to each other and that's really
weird and all this other kind of [__]
but I don't know I like I said I think
there's arguments and it's kind of
intriguing to think about that maybe the
whole thing was but like I said I think
the whole point of the movie was that
cuz they had a couple conversations
earlier about just kind of like
accepting reality you know what I mean
because that was kind of the whole point
of their of him and his wife's whole
thing where you know they lost
themselves in this limbo Dimension
because they could do whatever they
wanted and they could build a whole
entire world just for themselves and
stuff like that but they just got lost
in it and then he started freaking out
because he couldn't distinguish the
dream world from reality any anymore
which started flipping him out and then
he accidentally implanted the idea in
her head that her world wasn't real he
was really just trying to get her out of
the limbo but when she came back to
reality she didn't believe that was
reality either and so then she ended up
killing herself perhaps thinking that
that would wake her up you know what I
mean CU it's significant that she killed
herself by jumping out of a window
because they they established several
times that the kick
is like that feeling like when you fall
you know what I mean when you're falling
asleep and you're just like you know and
it wakes you up like you feel like I
have that all the time one of my major
things is like I'll be kind of like
drifting off to sleep and I'll dream
that I'm walking downstairs and I miss
one and that wakes me up yeah so they're
try they're talking about that so I
think it's significant that she jumped
out of window thinking oh if I jump out
of window I'll die in this dream and
I'll wake up in the real world but that
was the real world so she died you know
what what I mean so so there was a whole
thing about accepting particular
realities and she never could and then
he felt bad because he had implanted the
idea in her head and it kind of grew
into this big thing and so he knew that
it could be done because of that but
yeah there's
just there's like just so much [__]
detail in this movie that it's
absolutely crazy like I said I watched a
couple videos about it where they were
talking about all of the [__] that was
in there all the [__] that was going on
in the background like all the stuff
with like the numbers all the stuff that
people said um you know that kind of uh
you know sort of um what's the word I'm
looking for the kind of like matched up
with other things and it's just insane
how intricate this script was like how
well thought out it was and it's really
something that you can't get a handle on
just watching it one time this is
definitely a very very
rewatchable film cuz you miss so much
because there's just like so much stuff
going on at the same
time um football Pharaoh says Jen I love
your analysis here it's fun to listen to
I respectfully disagree though I think
he is dreaming at the end and the point
is that real or not it's not important
because it's real to him yeah I honestly
I think I think that's kind of the whole
point of the movie is that whether it's
a dream at the end or it isn't a dream
he is not he doesn't really care anymore
I think he's dreaming too kind of like
kind of like out of Total Recall Arnold
Schwarzenegger yeah and this has been
slightly compared to that too just in
the sense that you don't know like
what's reality and what's not you think
Arnold's character was actually you know
getting rid of cohagen and finding all
the [__] uh Alien artifacts and
helping the no that he wasn't a secret
agent he got he got the trip that he
paid for it tells you right there in the
beginning he even picks the woman they
show the woman yeah everything that
happens in that movie exactly what he is
they show exactly the be like they for
didn't even foreshadow it they basically
tell you what's going to happen in the
movie and then that's what happens they
tell him you will absolutely believe it
absolutely he's like okay and they made
sure that he absolutely believed it in
the scene where they come in and they're
from recall and they're trying to save
him remember and [__] he's got the
gun to the guy from recalls head yeah
and he sees the sweat and Arnold pulls a
trigger kills him uh that was Arnold
[__]
that was Arnold's character [__]
doubl and dowo no this is real yeah this
is not something from recall from from
the recall company but no he he got the
he got the vacation he paid for but see
okay so I Haven fantasy I haven't seen
it in a while but didn't the Total
Recall people yeah didn't they have
protocols in place for somebody who got
like a little too into it and actually
did think it was like real so so
everything that happened like they knew
they were like oh [__] okay well let's
do I don't think he was having the
embolism though no they just told him he
was having the emis and then they got
him to [__] commit to it by killing
that guy from recall like I said I think
everything in there was planned right
because he told them he I'll never know
the difference you will never know the
difference it's like it and he didn't
and he didn't you're right so yeah so I
don't think there's I mean yeah but a
recall he got the vacation secret I I
don't think there's any mystery the ego
trip he bought the ego trip yeah away
from himself but this movie I definitely
think is open to interpretation but I
don't know if the whole thematic thing
is necessarily open to interpretation
like I said whether he's in a dream at
the end or not it the point of it is it
doesn't matter he chose not to care
about it anymore he let go of that and
he's like you know what my kids are here
I'm here his father-in-law Michael Kane
was there and he's just like whether
this is a dream or not I'm accepting it
this is reality and he left all of that
behind another thing that people pointed
out too is that um when they're arguing
that the last part is reality is that a
lot of people have thought that the top
was his totem yeah the top was not his
totem that was his wife's totem he he
says that very clearly in the
movie so a lot of people they don't ever
actually say outright what his totem is
because his big thing is like well
you're not really supposed to let other
people like handle it or T it's supposed
to be just you so only you know
that if you're in reality or not so a
lot of people have speculated that his
totem is actually his wedding ring
because in when he's in a dream he has
his wedding ring on on his left hand uh
when he's in reality he doesn't and so a
lot of astute viewers have pointed out
that his wedding ring is actually his
totem but they never say that outright
because everybody just assumes it's the
top but it's not they say that the top
was Mal's uh totem so so he just uses
that because of her you know what I mean
so like I said I don't know if that was
intended but it did seem it doesn't seem
to be um accidental that every time he's
in reality he doesn't have his wedding
ring on and in whenever he's in a dream
he does so so so most people have said
that that's probably his totem but they
didn't like say that
outright yeah I'm hungry too Robert
Walsh says new subscriber and thanks
Rocky Horror review years back got me
here oh okay oh thank you very much oh
my gosh I remember doing that um Zan
said I've been listening to you guys
since you did that show on the order of
the solar Temple yeah remember that one
see you give me a lot of content so
sending movies is just my way of saying
thanks thank you very much well we do
appreciate it very much and which I mean
I like which I love this movie and I had
like I had said I had only seen it one
time before but Zan is getting ready to
partake in the in in the damn Japanese
Classics like L Wolf and Cub series and
zichi got to watch out man zichi there's
over for like a 100 movies and it'll
kind of
repeat um they're kind of Samy if you
watch too many of them CU it just went
on for a long long time but shitaro KATU
man you'll like him and he
produced Lone Wolf and Cub and that's
his brother playing this doing the star
playing L wolf but uh yeah
man anything sh shintaro KATU man
anything related to that guy he's
[__] awesome he could sing he could
[__] do cocaine he can do everything
he can sing and do cocaine sing and do
cocaine all at once yeah friend of mine
owns a toy company in Japan he owns HL
Pro which make Japanese figures he knew
about shantar he's lived there
forever he's got a Japanese wife he's
from France actually and he said that
shitaro KATU was like [__] known for
going to these real high-end clubs and
getting [__] loaded and doing great
shows just start singing karaoke to
everybody body it wasn't even you know
said he was a real good guy everybody
loved him but he he would just start
singing and putting on a show in the
club you know not for not for any money
just free doing
karaoke man they love their karaoke yeah
but he's he was a great singer kind of
like a Japanese Frank Sinatra and he was
good with a sword killed a dude with a
sword by accident not on purpose yeah
yeah making a movie yeah Danny says is
there nudity in this film uh no not that
I remember not really much swear either
I think it's only PG-13 which is crazy
to think about cuz it's kind of an
R-rated concept I guess I didn't notice
any of that now you mention I didn't
yeah I didn't really you won't notice
like I said it's it's a heist film the
movie's all business uh Danny says uh
cuz Tammy said yes Danny they're all
naked and then Danny said hard pass I
don't want to see Michael Kane sagy ball
back um Michael Kane isn't naked in this
nobody's naked in this that's I know but
they're joking yeah uh he ask where does
it take place and what year is it set in
they never specify um you're just meant
to assume it's sometime in the future
when the military has developed dream
sharing technology but it doesn't like I
said it's not super sci-fi it's not like
super futuristic or anything it's
slightly futuristic but you're mostly in
dreams yeah and it's like and it's set
there's a couple scenes that are
ostensibly in real cities like there's
some in Paris and there's some in um
Mombasa which I don't think they
actually filmed there I think they
filmed that in Morocco or something on
who's hosting the dream they're going to
have their own Motif you know with Le
out DiCaprio's [__] guy when he's
dreaming it's all stylish sometimes when
other people that are dreaming it's kind
of
crappy Mombasa right although he was
dreaming that wasn't he he Dre anything
I think he was dreaming it too he just
had different styles yeah it's like it's
said in dream worlds but it's still
realistic but the whole thing about it
is that and they get into this as some
of the rules of like constructing these
subconscious worlds is that well you
want it to look kind of realistic but
not like any kind of real place they're
like so don't use because I think at one
point like when he's kind of teaching
Ari Adney the ropes and she makes this
bridge that's like a real Bridge like in
Paris that she walks across and he's
like yeah don't do that because um
there's all these reasons like why why
you shouldn't do it like they have all
these complicated rules and then they
have all these things where you have to
construct it like a maze because it's
essentially like
constructing like Video Game World like
you don't want the dreamer who you're
trying to extract information from to
realize that someone else is in their
dream so you want it to be kind of
seamless so it's like so they almost
construct it kind of like a maze so that
they don't see the edges you know what I
mean and so they're like well we don't
usually like we like it to be realistic
but not super recognizable you know so
there's that um so it's not really set
like I said there's scenes that are set
in Paris and there's scenes that are set
in Mombasa but other than that it takes
place in kind of and there's scenes that
are set in like la like downtown LA um
but it's not a
realistic it's kind of a slightly
hyperreal um iteration of that you know
what I mean so it's not like super set
in one place um yeah Zan said I'm going
to check out the Japanese movies Tom
recommended just busy working I'm at
work right now of Japanese movies a lot
of people have pointed out that this
movie the concept of it at least was may
have been partially inspired by the 2006
animated Japanese film paprika which I
haven't seen but I've seen like a um uh
like a big complicated breakdown of I
think Brandon tenel did one so I've seen
like big chunks of it and it does
seem similar in concept and some of the
scenes are homaged here but I don't know
how similar it is cuz I haven't seen the
whole thing you know what I mean so
there's that um let's see Hugo said if
you like this film check out Denzel
Washington's Deja Vu and source code I
don't think I've seen either one of them
I've heard of them but I haven't seen
them s just said that he said didn't
come and see oh yeah I can't wait to see
that like I said I heard it Soul
crushing but okay I'm into that that's
the Russian one right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I said he karian Edition yeah
he said then I won't send any for a
while but I want you to see that one
Jenny yeah I want to see it too
he's interested to see interested to
hear if you consider it a horror movie I
do see it it's interesting because I do
see it come up in some lists of horror
movies even though it's technically not
supposed to be a horror movie but I kind
of feel like it maybe has the same thing
as that British movie from the 80s
called threads which isn't really made
as a horror movie but most people
absolutely see it as a horror movie
which I think it is I reviewed that a
long time ago and honestly I think
that's one of my most popular videos
that's the one that I get the most
comments on for real like that movie is
[__] up it's like a realistic nuclear
war film and so it's uh pretty
depressing but yeah all right so I guess
Tom's getting kind of antsy and hungry
back there so we haven't eaten much
today I had one piece of chicken that's
all I've eaten today we can go we can go
get Chinese food if you want oh well
that sounds like are they still open
yeah I guess they I guess they all right
so we're man we're GNA go get some
Chinese food how exciting all right so
thanks everybody for dropping by this
evening uh thank you zanada again for
sending this movie like I said we'll do
the Departed um next Monday on next the
thing now Wednesday's show I'm actually
kind of excited I know this is kind of
messed up but I'm actually kind of
excited about this somebody recommended
on the last episode that we do a show
about the 2001 Anthrax attacks okay
which I thought we had done a show about
but we didn't I was thinking of the
Chicago Tylenol thing which happened
back in the 80s um we did we did a show
on that yeah there there is a lot so so
yeah so we're going to do a show about
that on Wednesday night so hopefully you
guys can join us for that should be
really good and really interesting
there's actually a Netflix documentary
series about that which I probably want
to watch at some point like tonight or
tomorrow so yeah so that should be good
so hopefully you guys can join us for
that and we'll see you guys again on
Wednesday night good night